we saw how we could find the length of a
line which was neither parallel to the
x-axis nor parallel to the y-axis
but the procedure to find the length was
a bit lengthy
to avoid repeating the same procedure
again we can generalize the formula to
find the length of such a line
let one of the endpoints be a
x1 comma y1
and b
x2 comma y2
to get the length of a b we need to form
a triangle in which a b is the
hypotenuse
so we drop a perpendicular to the x-axis
and then draw another perpendicular to
bc
so the coordinates of point d would be
x2 comma y1
x2 will be here on the x-axis
and y1 will be here on the y-axis
now we find the length of a d and b d
and then use pythagoras theorem to find
the length of a b
since b d is parallel to the y axis
it will equal the absolute value of y2
minus y1
and since ad is parallel to the x-axis
it will equal absolute value of x2 minus
x1
using the pythagoras theorem in this
triangle we get a b squared equals a d
squared plus b d squared
substituting these values the expression
will equal
x 2 minus x 1 the whole square
plus y2 minus y1 the whole squared
so length of a b will be the square root
of the addition of these two
now the formula has been generalized all
we need to know is the coordinates of
the two endpoints and we can just feed
it into this formula
notice that x1 and y1 are coordinates of
point a
and x2 and y2 are coordinates of point b
this by the way is called the distance
formula
let's zoom out to understand a special
case of the distance formula
if we have a line like this which starts
from the origin then the formula gets
simpler
let the coordinates of point a be x
comma y
the coordinates of the origin are 0
comma 0.
in this case x 2 y 2 are x y and x 1 y 1
are 0 comma 0.
so using the distance formula we get the
length of o a as the square root of x
minus 0 the whole squared plus y minus 0
the whole squared
that would equal
square root of x squared plus y squared
if the line segment starts from the
origin its length will be the square
root of x squared plus y squared where x
and y are the coordinates of the other
endpoint